see that that's a tear of happiness for
the fact that my mouth is on fire hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot one it's the show of hot question
even how to ring and today I'm joined by
the bold and adventurous coyote Peterson
you can catch you - tremendously popular
YouTube channel brave wilderness where
people tune in by the millions to see
coyote go on strange animal adventures
and get bit by dangerous insects all for
your entertainment coyote welcome to the
show thank you for having me this looks
much more dangerous than some of the
things that I've encountered in the past
365 days so we'll nervous I'm not used
to chicken bullet ants no problems
chicken wings you see what happened it's
a new frontier how are you with hot food
I actually had my very first hot wing
just the other day I am NOT a spicy food
person so this should be very
interesting
[Music]
[Music]
this first one is sriracha sriracha is
no big deal okay I didn't think about
perhaps sriracha sauce before won't full
spicy okay look I think that's the first
reaction that a lot of people have when
they watch your videos is what's up with
this guy so if you don't mind I'd like
to get your origin story a little bit
what does the coyote nickname come from
when I was kid my mom is take my sister
and I across the country we travel all
throughout the United States
we Dalton Utley end up in Tucson Arizona
and there's a lizard there called a
Regal horned lizard my favorite lizard
in the world but they're really really
camouflaged so to find these lizards I
used to actually follow road runners
from now the road runners love to eat
horned lizard so like the Warner
Brothers cartoon my mom started calling
me coyote because I was chasing road
runners around a desert looking for
these lizards and I never actually found
a horned lizard by following a road
runner but I guess in the end I got a
pretty cool nickname who's your guy that
ranks all the systems Brett right
there's got to go uh he's like this
ranked people's performances and how
long they last
Brett Baker hot Winker Bieber fan
shout-out to Brett Baker a name that
comes up over the course of this show
often has he been on the show not yet
not yet you really should get Brett on
the show and I'll bring a bullet in and
if Brett gets all the way through then
you can get a bullet into rats so
someone who's eaten to Carolina Reapers
I know that sometimes the consequences
of a shoot can last long after the
cameras cut yeah I don't even know what
a Carolina Reaper is I'm assuming that's
a pepper of some shot at pepper in the
world how does it that's in my world -
twice you didn't learn the first time
pan your bulb
what is the bite or sting that had the
worst aftermath worst biter sting I've
ever gotten well there's been a lot of
them I'd have to say it's the most
recent thing that I went through where I
was wearing a bee beard and it was an
epic fail Chris we were working with a
bee specialist said he's done this
before maybe two or three stings
okay two or three stings is going to be
fun you know a good kind of comedic
episode just shave off my fur beard and
wear a bee beard isn't what happened was
some rogue bees came into the swarm it
was on my face and once I got stung once
and then another time we started
releasing a pheromone that was a fight
for a moment and before I do it my face
became the target of multiple beestings
and 32 stings later I was in incredible
pain my face swelled up almost
immediately my eyes were watering that
said it looked like I was crying it
wasn't actually crying I was just like
imagine how my face will probably end up
by the end of today and it was extremely
painful and the after effect was about
48 hours of my face looking like a lump
and potato so don't don't do be beards
[Music]
mm-hmm something's happening
something's happening inside of the
mouth right now feels like little ants
starting to bite me mm-hmm-hmm amazingly
brave wilderness is now the most watched
digital wilderness channel beating out
legacy brands like National Geographic
but it's important to pay homage to
those who paved the way so what I want
to do is bounce some of the most
legendary figures in the field off of
you and then just get your snap reaction
okay good yeah all right let's go
because I love that you brought that
question because you always have to talk
about where you get your inspiration
wrong you know I love that all right
first one Jane Goodall
yes that's what a lot of people don't
ever bring up to me with our brand you
know we're getting more and more in a
direction of how do you promote
conservation how do you bring all these
animals to a public eye that need help
and I think somebody like Jane is a
wonderful example of somebody that's
driven spear for conservation for
costumes and I've been a kid Justin Oh
Schmidt
oh yeah Justin you know Justin of course
I'm actually I think an be working with
Justin this summer were birthed
participating in a documentary that's
being done in Arizona by a student there
that is researching this pain sting
index and was actually Justin's
experimentations with all these luck
she's got this amazing chart we found on
the internet because I've been
some about harvester ants and
everybody's like you got achieve this
chart with all these other things I know
anything about it to time he's been
stung by absolutely everything you name
it he's been stung by he kind of sets
that this is a so-called chart Scoville
scale Scoville scale that's what he's
done with with bites and stings so yeah
I carry his a little chart on my phone
all the time it's awesome
Steve Steve Irwin well I grew up
watching Steve I mean I was the kid that
was in my backyard trying to catch
snapping turtles pretending that they
were crocodiles
I had the khaki shorts I had khaki
shirts like if you didn't love Steve you
don't belong in the animal space period
miss them for sure as everybody does and
and every single day when we work on our
content I just think about the fact that
somebody like that inspired us and we're
hoping to carry on the torch in a sense
for the next generation man waters
always got a wolf on there mm-hmm what's
cool you ever just drink these like
straight out bottles like prepare like
in your training no I said no it's never
occurred to me to drag yeah I mean I
don't go around like grabbing random
insects being like tomorrow's the bullet
hit a couple more tarantula Hawks Ayana
it might work though it might all right
so of course people want to hear about
bites and stings but for my money your
best videos are these ones where you
make a unique connection with the wild
animal on set when you think about the
times that you've established some sort
of unique bond while filming are there
any that stand out oh yeah well and
thank you for mentioning that because
yes a lot of people want to know about
the Pyke's instincts but it's really
only about 10% of what's on our Channel
probably the one that stands out the
most is the Ocelot which was one of our
most phenomenal encounters we've ever
had wild Ocelot in jungles of Costa Rica
it was young ones just a juvenile but
came out of nowhere in the woods I mean
we did know that there it had been
spotted in that area we're told he kind
of walked this trail at night you may
stumble upon it and sure enough we were
out there looking for eyelash fibers
butcher these beautiful colorful snakes
these Vipers that live in the trees and
we are these paws coming out of darkness
I mean I've never jumped so harmonicas
you think Jaguar oh no we're going to
get that by Jaguar and
here comes a slow Ocelot out of nowhere
and she was just the most playful
incredible creature in the world and
Mark our directors like dude we gotta
shoot an episode on this right now so we
all just start scrambling to be like
play with the Ocelot whatever happens
just roll the camera so we just kept
rolling and they got some phone with us
I was like you guys are in my playground
like we're going to hang out all night
right I got the boy is like 2:00 in the
morning really mad like we run out of
camera batteries here like we got to
head back to base camp in that office I
wanted to play non-stop so it was pretty
cool experience I'm never going to
forget not much good Thank You coyote
hot little spider mm-hmm
all right coyote we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
Graham and what we do is we do a deep
dive on our guest Instagram we pull
interesting pictures that need more
context I'll show you the picture that
you just tell me the bigger story does
that sound good yep
all right laptop please again with the
laptop is this when you've got a Kylie
Jenner lip kit or you know we probably
could have called that the Kylie Jenner
lip challenge I'll see it at this point
I was the most afraid that my lips were
going to pop I don't know how far a
human lips can stretch but they just
kept going and going after about 15
minutes when we knew I was going to go
into anaphylactic shock which can't
happen if you're stung a bunch by bees
we knew I was kind of in the clear and
then we went to Chipotle and we walked
in and I looked like that and the kids
work and they were like you kind of look
like that guy coyote Peterson and I was
like I am coyotes and I've got a
starting bunch times by bees and they
give spree chapelier it was a great day
oh I love that guy you and Jeff Goldblum
you're a Jurassic Park guy huge Jurassic
Park fan the biggest Jurassic Park fan
there is arguably actually brought my
little dr. Ian Malcolm toy from when I
was kid on Conan the producers of Conan
wanted to know everything like that I
was going to do and like I start going
down this road I think I got some tricks
up my sleeve they're like there's no
check so soon
better just not tell you about my little
totally then and what I love about that
photo right there
is I added my arm around him and he had
his arm around me and I kind of he was
like kind of squeezing my shoulder I
tickled his ribs and I gave him that
Jurassic Park lap that he did in the
helicopter
and that moe he's laughing and then he
turns me goes that's my laugh one more
for you face-to-face with the Wolverine
hmm that was so much work people don't
realize how tough it was to convince
steve kroschel that I could get face to
face with the Wolverine Steve crow shows
been raising Wolverines for 30 years and
we showed up as I guess t back got to
get an enclosure with the Wolverine it's
like I don't know what you're talking
about I thought you wanted to take
pictures we were like no we're no
boulder he's like I gotta be writable
green so there's this whole panic he put
me through some incredible tests and
when I find they got to me band who's
the Wolverine face to face it was like
childhood dream come true most
incredible animal I've ever been
face-to-face with
[Music]
ghost pepper and blueberry I have
blueberries for breakfast actually if
that's going to work in my favor this
one is actually kind of blue like a
blueberry mmm a little bit of a
blueberry kick to it
what's the animal myth or falsehood that
drives you crazy Asst people are
terrified of shark now make no mistake I
grew up watching jaws love Spielberg
loved that movie
but there were a lot of misnomers that
came from a movie like that and
subsequent movies that have personified
sharks as these villains these killers
that are just out there to eat humans
not not to say that sharks are not
dangerous need to be treated with
complete respect they certainly do but
there's a lot of people to have an
unnecessary fear of sharks any kid
that's out there I don't want them to be
afraid to go to the beach because a
shark might come Andy Andy I love sharks
sharks are there they're doing amazing
things for the environment lips are
tingling that's probably a good sign
right that last one I actually kind of
snuck up after the fact and you know
when it hits is like when you're
breathing out breathing again it's like
that's nice breathing out it's like a
dragon's breath that's I do it people
always wonder I'm always going like yeah
yeah and that's what I'm doing I'm
getting a little instant relief I feel
like one of the police's dragons from
Game of Thrones
reigns right in your mouth
hmmm how look flavor to it you can tell
right away
so what starting to burn my face
something happening now something's
definitely happening there you have
whatever told what I want to talk about
survival for a second because as the
coyote pack knows it's not all just
cuddly animals and venomous snakes just
so you guys know I'm starting to sweat
now mm-hmm all right but then I wear
this leather hat yeah okay
what's your move if you're hiking along
the trail and you find yourself
face-to-face with an angry grizzly bear
ma'am did you know that we have this
situation happen to us this past summer
in Alaska do you know that with a bear
scare face-to-face with the mother brown
bear under three cubs that was crazy so
a lot of times they tell you to carry
bear spray right which is like a super
intensified pepper spray which probably
ranks somewhere up in here that spray
when it hits the Bears nose and eyes
usually will stun the girl what happen
to me what's going on right now the bear
will go in the opposite direction where
you run into trouble is that if a bear
does charge you don't have their spray
if it's a brown bear or grizzly you drop
on the ground you get into a ball and
you protect your neck brown bears aren't
so much out there to you as they are to
just eliminate the territorial threat a
black bear on the other hand is another
story they can be about three to four
hundred pounds and a black bear will eat
you so if you get attacked by a black
bear you fight with everything you've
got
but brown bear grizzly bear on the
ground plate done Wow look at that deep
now this one has look literally has a
bomb on it no bomb beyond insanity
nowhere it's just a back of your throat
with a little dangly punching bag yeah
they could get stuck on there and like
damn it that's all of that then I'm
gonna go legit see that there's a lot I
see you doused it right there I'm gonna
take some big bite darling don't like
reserved right back
something's happening right soon as I
think I've said that I'm going this was
slow onset of life there's a way yeah
your body reacts to it responds to it in
ways that you never really thought
possible happens up until you start
clean in the clouds or do it today and
then that's along its arm it was really
tough to get yourself to force yourself
to swallow something that hot you don't
really have to clean the wings coyote no
moving all the way over I respect it
yeah our commenters are always clamoring
for the guests that they want to see on
the show oh it's so hot right now I
can't eat and I imagine that it's kind
of the same for you that people are
always clamoring for the stunts for the
animal faces to face that they want to
see what's the one thing now get eaten
by a whale everybody wants to see the
old Pinocchio yeah I'm down you would be
surprised how many people are like can
you get swallowed by whale and like it
doesn't work like that though like I
don't think you can't be swallowed by a
whale I actually have it here guys under
your type you see that that's a tear of
happiness for the fact that my mouth is
on fire
all right oh gosh all right the sauce
will blow you away
double bite and on two three
well rue barks I know you're watching
Brett Mario my gosh write that now oh
man you're calm the water whoops that's
gonna be a tough one to get down
so you've used a lot of strange things
and your time on YouTube you've had
killer bee honey you had that a durian
fruit oh but the regional food in Ohio
yeah it might be stranger weirder than
all of those things even so what I want
to do is bounce some of the regional
foods and Ohio off of you then just get
your reaction that's not good while my
nose is running mm-hmm maybe I don't
have like tissues you just you guys want
that running this hmm okay I'm ready you
had a terminator I have actually tried
to eat that once with a friend hold on
but there's like it's like there's like
a small like that mad dog is in the back
of my throat I think it just kicked me
on this side over here like a little
like flake of something just went tonsil
crazy ah yes that burger is so big so
big I got the farmers like there's no
more bun no more these top is I just
tried to like down the meat I couldn't
finish it
what about Buckeyes yeah yeah yeah ooh
Buckeyes all the time those are kind of
like Reese's pcs on like I don't know
357 Mad Dog yeah they're awesome have
you ever had Cincinnati style chili oh
yeah and my editor chris loves skyline
chili which is i guess it originated in
cincinnati right yeah i don't hang out
in the editing suite after chris has
been to skylight
how's your face - feelin right actually
nobody ever asked how you're doing
Thank You Kerry I appreciate that
looking out for you man so here's I
would say is it's uh it's burnin like it
does my lips are on fire my mouth is on
fire my tongue swelling a little bit
very uncomfortable but at the same time
coyote I invited uses a show yes I feel
like I have to put up a front I have to
be professional so don't let that
vulnerability show I try not to let that
vulnerability show but for you for you
that would be like if I invited you out
new swamp and I was like hey man let's
keep it by snapping turtles and then I
was like you just you do it you know
what it would be like if you brought me
out to the swamp and you're like let's
go look at snapping turtles and then
you've got a snapping turtle and you
freaked out yeah you know what I mean I
was older guy doesn't know what he's
doing over here man it you guys don't
realize like you've watch and you're
like huh manatee can't be that hot I
didn't think it was dinner I really
thought that like you've got other guys
you like having trouble just controlling
the amount of fire that's in my mouth
right now
this is Blair's Megadeth sauce with
liquid rage it's tradition around here
to put a little dab on the last wing is
it already on the wing it is already on
the wing but I put a little extra for
the people out there you don't have to
feel I'm happy to do Dereham ever drink
it out in bottle seems like a loaded
question no oh just bubble did you see
that it's just I'm not gonna drink it
out of the bottle so I won't be that guy
but I will give a good wall talk of it
there they're given [ __ ] that's very
legit that looks dangerous right there
right that's like ketchup I was really
confident when we were right here I like
this is not a problem
we lull you into that false sense of
security and then yeah it's like what
I'm gonna trip on a really tall flight
of stairs and there's no way you're
going to stop yourself on the way down
all right if I stall long enough
all right guess we're going to see what
happens we're gonna cheers to visitors
see on the other side hmm
now wake you up mm-hmm mega jack really
legit I have one more question for you
whether it's a travel show like Bizarre
Foods or a science show like Mythbusters
there's always the delicate balance
where you're trying to educate but at
the same time you're doing everything
that you can to draw eyeballs when it
comes to brave wilderness what is your
response to the critics who just think
that you're some macho idiot we should
just get eaten by a komodo dragon what's
your end game actually love it when we
have articles that are written about us
they're like this guy's a maniac because
we don't get funny I'm really not a
macho maniac kind of guy and that does
bring people in but then once they find
the channel and they find episodes with
Manatee and ocelots and conservation
projects about little tiny class frogs
the leaf frogs when Costa Rican
rainforests are like this stuff is
actually really educational while we do
love you guys watching on YouTube would
you watching us I'd explore your local
and state parks but really at the end of
the day for everybody to walk away
knowing that they've gotten some sort of
education even the bites thing episodes
are dispelling myths and encouraging you
to admire these animals from a safe
distance let me take the Bison things
let me get up close to any animal matter
what it is if you admire from safe
distance will be just fine
and I'll take some time to say that you
should admire bleers Megadeth sauce
perhaps from a safe distance but not you
coyote Peterson don't ever mess around
with Megadeth my face right now is like
it's like have you ever liked taking a
bunch of bottle rockets cut off their
stems and like put them inside of a milk
jug to see what would happen no never in
my life no huh
me neither but that's kind of what the
inside of my mouth feels like right now
you know how it goes this camera this
camera this camera lets people know what
you have going on in your life well
we're continuing to make episodes on the
brailers Channel and I'm really excited
to announce they're actually just wrote
my very first book and a lot of times
you hear about people who have ghost
writers there's no ghostwriter on this
book
was threatened by me it's a series of
chapters that are their individual own
little short stories that are some of
the grand adventures we've gone on it's
called great adventures and it is online
right now for pre-sale and it will be in
stores on bookshelves everywhere common
September September 19th
[Music]
raelia shows triple atomic wings like I
was like I was trying to back up my car
to park in the parking lot and I was
like this way I was like oh I don't
think I shot a car as interesting I hope
you have a DD for this one hey what's
going on hot ones fans if you like the
video maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you liked
the video subscribe thank you very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend